pump the brakes kids let's talk about
that Ru garbage.com your One-Stop shop
for everything garbage you got tickets
coming up and we got a little merch
there check it out yes also this week
we're going to be in Florida maybe a few
tickets couple tickets left in Tampa
those two shows are about to be sold out
that we're going to Danny Beach Florida
limited tickets and we're also going to
Raleigh limited tickets there and we're
going to Louisville and also Cleveland
and Columbus gets those tickets the live
shows are a good time gang yeah more
dates coming welcome so another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're going to be
classy they're after just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at titties in the new
edition she's down in Arizona doing a
little muelling okay coyotes got their
hands on her hopefully she's back in a
couple weeks not empty-handed my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video of album on YouTube
as you know those numbers are cooking
then the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com gang check it out it's a
[__] party over there yeah and the
second greatest website of all time that
Ru garbage.com get yourself some Dickies
and some merch over there cooking got
the domain name baby and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer Jordan
Air the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes and now you can get a little
sneak peek at him ladies on that Toby
cam give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McDonald everybody what up dudes
hey pal boys
from Jersey took the boat in like a
gentleman it's got a Navy
came over on the USS gabagool that's
what I'm talking about
gang the long hair ain't lying we could
not be more excited to have more
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he is a legendary stand-up comedian
actor podcaster and now author and you
may have seen him in but not limited to
Here We Go Gang put your seat belts on
it's a long one it's a worker we got
basketball we got our list we have NYPD
Blue analyze that Dickie Roberts ER Cold
Case Law and Order Special Victims Unit
Spider-Man 2 taxi The Longest Yard How I
Met Your Mother Everybody Hates Chris
Mad TV My Name is Earl Wizards of
Waverly police The Mentalist General
Hospital Children's Hospital Brooklyn
Nine-Nine Grudge Match he got Marin
Superior Donuts big city greens the many
Saints of Newark ComicView ymh WTF this
is not happening hot ones tigerbelly
Danny's house lights out with David
Spade the cabin The Comedy Store and of
course The Joe Rogan Experience he has
multiple stand-up specials including
2000 16th socially unacceptable and
Netflix the degenerates he was a long
time host of The Amazing podcast the
Church of What's Happening Now and he is
currently the host of the Fantastic
Uncle Joey's joint and let me tell you
this right now he is the author of this
book right here tremendous the life of a
comedy Savage if you are a comedy fan
this is an absolute must read ladies and
gentlemen give it up for the legendary
Joey Diaz everybody let's go let's go
look at him what's happening you Savages
I am [__] embarrassed why why I'm
totally embarrassed by killing it for 30
years I love you guys thank you for
having me are you kidding me of course I
always take that boat from [__]
Jersey over I've been taking boats all
my life raps [__] submarines
submarines yeah I took a submarine from
Cuba I'm nowhere
and always comes downstairs she's like I
I looked at the immigration status yeah
your uncle came but I don't see you your
mom or your dad
via submarine Jack
pull the 23 in me ain't nothing there 23
and who we just popped up on the Hudson
[__] went over to Union City and the
rest was history
oh man I love it I'll say this though I
live out in Astoria in Queens and they
have a ferry there too taking that
fairies real classy instead of taking
the PATH train or the subway in like an
animal you take that you get a little
fresh air out there it's nice 19 bucks
round trip not bad if I take the train
I'm Gonna Save 13 bucks but I'm gonna
have a thousand when I have groovations
oh yeah I don't know where I'm going
this or not the guy that you know I know
he's still around they used to be a
train a guy on the train that the train
would the A train it would close the
doors and also the guy go can I have
your attention please I'm gonna walk the
train I got kovid I got a toenail I got
AIDS I got hepatitis C I got a [__]
pink eye and he just ran through like a
thousand ailments and then he'd say can
anybody help not really
[Laughter]
really I
can double toenail
the trains were great in New York said
now you get stabbed now yeah it ain't
great now it's not great yeah I still
remember getting on trains and like
[__] being straight
but having like a rough night the night
before and you see things moving and
you're like is that a [__] rat no
rat's on the train and there's thousands
of them and you're like God damn I gotta
stop smoking pot I gotta I gotta stop
eating corn flakes what the [__] I keep
seeing these little things and they used
to be mice in the 70s 80s and 90s
they're rats now now they got luggage
right they got [__] luggage and [__]
they're headed out to JFK for a weekend
asking you for a swipe yeah
um that's funny man Joey give us the
back story just a little bit a little
childhood uh give us give us the scoop
here Union City Union City it's just
Union City and then my father died and
my mom wanted to get out of the house
because it was creepy so she sold it and
moved to 88th Street oh so when I wore
west side or yeah this morning Upper
West Side guys
yeah the east side is kind of like
boring yeah there ain't nothing there
nah West Side you come out of the house
somebody's bleeding there's a [__]
you know it's always a story you know
not anymore 88th Street has like a
[__] Whole Foods on the clock oh yeah
yeah yeah it's real nice yeah I see
people sitting outside ah when I was a
kid the corner there was a photography
store and the family from this is
[__] crazy you guys are too young you
remember Dark Shadows was a show on ABC
in the afternoons okay a guy named
Barnabas Collins would come he was like
a [__] badass vampire with a big dick
and he couldn't bite you in the neck I
don't remember that but that fan if you
look it up it's hysterical their family
owned that thing and the kid that played
like the yeti Munster okay always worked
there who gives a [__] that was a long
time ago
stayed up there until about the third
grade
okay no stand up dead for the fifth
grade I moved to Jersey in 73. okay but
my mom always had a bar in Jersey
so my roots were kind of always always
there still still hanging out there yeah
so I lived on 88th Street went to PS 166
but my godmother lived on 148th and
Broadway I live up there and that was
the [__] neighborhood when you
watched the heights baby oh my God that
was a great neighborhood walk the 125
get chased by gangs you know it was
[__] it was a different world for a
child you know
and then uh moved to Jersey mom sold the
ball in 78 we got locked down
um
what was the name of the bar if you
don't mind me asking
it's a Cuban bar called it means the
watch in Spanish the clock they serve
food or just booze at the time yeah well
my mom had a Cuban joint that did
restaurant uh Cuban sandwiches and [__]
that's 32nd Street and
I think it's new your Palisade Avenue
and then when she closed that in like 56
she opened the bar then they went back
to Cuba had me and my sister damn went
badly [__] because my mom had gotten out
of Cube and that's why there's no record
of my mom coming here because my mom was
in a school dance with her sister when
she was 14 I think my mom was a year
older than her whatever and she was
missing so my mom went out looking for
her and the guy was raping my aunt
Rosita who's still alive
so my mom got a rum bottle and broke it
and stabbed the guy in the back so she
had to get her out of [__] Cuba
overnight they shipped it here because
we had family here okay so this happened
in Cuba and then she came here as like a
16 year old whatever the [__] he was her
and a cousin and they lived up in the
Bronx and they started running numbers
so she's a hustler yeah she's an earner
so that's how the whole numbers racket
came about and then
five or six years later she got she
hooked up with a Puerto Rican chicken
they opened up their own bank
and then it became dangerous it was like
a woman's little [__] little candy
store running numbers and they did it
and then uh they went back to Cuba came
back
my sister got stuck in Cuba my sister
wanted to finish out the school year
okay they went back after the revolution
or before the Revolution they went back
after the revolution okay to try to
bring my my grandmother back and all
those [__] people but those [__]
commies sure didn't want to go anywhere
they were just settled in Cuba then no
they didn't know it was on the horizon
they had no idea
so my parents came back my dad died a
week maybe a month after he got here I
was like three damn so that was like
shocking and then uh you know it just
flipped up the house
and I think 79 was when my mother died
and then I had to live with somebody and
some friends from the neighborhood took
me in and
I got into drugs and crime and you know
all the other [__] sure sure and then
I'm getting locked up and then came out
by that time I had a hint about comedy
but where I was from I didn't talk about
that it's like being in Philly who spoke
to you about [__] my god dude I'm
saying like if I [__] ever before I'm
dying to [__] look up with my
guidance counselors buried so I go
pissed on this [__] great
because
they never told you what was available
to you uh-huh you know in Philadelphia
had the same thing you know even now
dude I got uncles like what do you do
yeah they don't get it they don't
[__] they're all like bricklayers
yeah but no it was like tell us that
this is available it's impossible I'm a
[__] I could swim here from North
Bergen I would have came in done acting
classes I didn't know I was in the
comedy acting Mecca of the [__] world
sure so I never even thought about it
like all right I think freshman year I
joined some art the intro to Performing
Arts okay and we had a [__] I had to
do the song so I sang a lip sync
shattered by the Stones and the lady
pulled me aside she's like you're on to
something I'm like what am I on thing
I'm lip syncing
I'm not you know
it's crazy so what I was doing
Shakespeare monologues
you imagine if we would have gotten to
this like a Mason at 18. sure sure if we
would have all gotten into comedy or
there was no podcasting but anything
something we got into this we fell into
this by backwards you know backwards we
saw Eddie Murphy Raw we saw yeah
Delirious we saw something that inspired
well I could do what he does I didn't
start until I was 32. I had already
lived up here for like eight years
telling people I was an actor I was just
doing coke and working at a bar and then
wrong with that though no but we all do
that yeah I didn't start till I was 32
yeah 31 maybe no I was 30. yeah but I
was thinking about it since I was 27. so
you did a lot better than I did these
guys are all 10 years younger than me
yeah
it's crazy how you and I always I'm
angry about a lot of things like how can
you not want to do something that you
know is going to change your life yeah
like this is how junkied up I was like I
always knew listen
I don't know what I got to offer but I'm
better than that [__] guy on NBC sure
sure okay I'm better than that one
[__] I got him I could out-joke
that [__] to death okay you you
get that anger you get one guy and
you're like I'm funny in that [__]
guy you know and you just and then you
get into it that took me you were going
to an open mic I just went to watch for
the first time and I was like oh these
people [__] stop like I'm like I can
do it just as bad as that I think I was
on stage
[Laughter]
I was wearing a Blazer and sweatpants
it's so weird how you like I got right
before I got locked up there was a guy
that didn't kind of like me we didn't
like each other he wasn't a bad guy you
know like when you sure you just don't
get along you act a weird way one day
and now it ruined in I try to apologize
to the guy but he was just a hard-ass
guy and he came up to me once and he
goes listen I know you don't like me
I know you don't like me I would I had
to be maybe 28 at the time and he goes
but do you know what I did before I had
this job he goes I worked on
entertainment for 25 years in Las Vegas
he goes you got to get into comedy and
I'm like this [__] Humpty Dump
[__] trying to tell me what but
like a week later I got arrested
like right after he told me that I don't
resonate with not even a week later I
got arrested and that always you know
and I'm like what the [__] he know and
then I got out and I [__] went tried
to get into school and then I got
sentenced gotcha and when I got
sentenced was when I was wait a second
with a felony what am I gonna do what I
get out yeah I can't even be a [__]
acupuncturist
imagine did you want to do that anything
I I mean I can't cut hair
you can't get a license you could yeah
[Applause]
no but but when you're [__] [__]
and you're 30. you're too so sweet and
the [__] roads are closing Tanya you
know every road is closed when you're
30. you know if you think your life's
over when you're [__] 20 wait till
you're 30. and you're already like and
you got a felony on you yeah you got a
felony you got some chick pregnant she's
hunting you down the grandmother wants
to suck your dick you know and now
you're like really now you're pressured
to get into something like you're gonna
be [__] I'm gonna be 30 yeah I [__]
around I ate Quaaludes I got hepatitis I
got you know I gotta settle down that
was where I was at that sure that's a
scary listen when you're 20 and you have
an idea like I'm gonna go to college to
be an underwater biologist and then you
get there and you're like I don't like
[__] being underwater inside but I'll
become a biologist sure you're on the
right path you're at least in that one
guys like you and I we didn't have man
we could have gone to work with Uncle
Vinnie at the yeah sure we could have
gone to the Fruit Stand or we could have
worked at the warehouse yeah you don't
have that and
stays with you for a while like oh I
want to be an actor [__] I can't even
work in a Fruit Stand
yeah I don't even know the Tangerine is
like you know what I'm saying like so
now you so we we tend to get jobs that
are money you know like when you're 20
only I got a good job yeah I'm an
elevate a union I make 38 now I was
waiting tables yeah and then when you're
31 day you're like I gotta do something
that I like
this ain't gonna work it's bad enough I
gotta get up and go to work
it's bad enough I don't want to do it
I'd much rather sell Coke
I'd much rather cut through the shake
and sell cold now you're speaking about
somebody once a month you know I'll make
ends meet but that that always it's not
gonna work for you sure it's not gonna
[__] work did you stay all through
high school did you did you do high
school no no where did you were pretty
were you into drugs at that point like
pretty heavy or no yeah yeah 80 listen
79 my mom died I had already done Coke
one time I wasn't happy about it
I was basically a pothead gotcha but my
friends went to Zeppelin and all that
[__] so acid and mescaline was big when
I was growing up
so and lewds too
everywhere yeah those are good things
too but uh
[__] fun loots they're like unicorns
their generation we only heard stories
yeah your aunt your aunt will get drunk
at Thanksgiving but you ever do quails
like what [__] Gorilla Biscuits
I leave for lacrosse Camp you know
people weren't scared of them then like
if you come out with a quaalude no
people I guess listen it's five o'clock
on a Friday you got nothing to do you
got a job but yeah you don't really want
to go to it tomorrow it's four dollars
yeah loot up a quaalude is four [__]
dollars and it's like drinking 18
[__] beers for the eight that you're
already gonna drink okay so for the four
dollar when you're [__] 18 what would
you rather do sure pay six for a [__]
shipping six dollars for a case or are
you chipping four dollars for a [__]
gorilla biscuit which will take you a
lot longer and you'll have a story in
the morning because either you'll pass
out I mean I got a thousand stories
where I just woke up in [__] always
freezing with like a hooded sweatshirt
on and people would have said you would
have [__] lost a finger no I wouldn't
I'm on a quaalude I'm on a real vaccine
not this [__] three month thing you
know I slept outside one night I had to
be like 18 degrees I woke up the next
day I had frost on me and [__] but I
didn't lose a hand you know what I'm
saying like these kids today would lose
the [__] hand they lost their hand I
fell asleep outside
you know
oh man holy [__] okay holy all right
okay let's talk about ladder ladder
listen here's the here's the hard truth
tell you this right now cue ball what's
that you don't know when uh when the big
guy's gonna pull your card you know what
I mean when you're gonna check the [__]
out of this Odell expire I'm planted
something next week I think late
checkout
but gang do yourself a favor get over
the ladder get yourself some term life
insurance you don't want to leave the
squad holding the bag when you kick it
make sure everybody's taken care of head
off to the Afterlife with easy peace of
mind yeah don't be a dirtbag for the one
time in your life ladder is 100 digital
no doctors no needles no paperwork when
you apply for three million in coverage
or less yeah uh just get your phone a
laptop and answer a few quick questions
about your health ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved you
choose uh so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladderlife.com
garbage baby there's no hidden fees you
can cancel anytime you even get a full
refund if you cancel within the first 30
days because they're good people's baby
they got your back one more time that's
ladderlife.com today do it yeah wrap on
the gates of hell with a clear
conscience
don't be sweating in our in in eternity
will you okay let's talk about Aura Aura
Aura Aura gang do you take about a
million and photos only to leave them on
your phone or get them lost in your
files what if you could have all your
photos on one gorgeous frame well now
you can with the connected frame from
aura yes name the best digital photo
frame by wire cutter the strategist and
featured in hundreds of gift guides Aura
frames are guaranteed to make Mom and
Grandma smile because you know what's
coming up it's Mother's Day baby don't
look like a bozo yeah cram one of these
down our throat yeah shut her up zip it
now you can see the kids I don't got to
come over every week yeah it takes just
a few minutes of nudes on there get the
heart pump and tasteful obviously it
takes just a few minutes to set up for
years of enjoyment uh they were nice
enough to send us a couple I got it at
the house send it to the bird I sent it
to my mom I said bam shut up I'll Ram
this on RAM this down your pipe and then
my sister I don't have kids but my
sister I send pics of hansy over but the
kids uh my sister and my brother all
dump pictures of the little grandkids on
there I love it you invite as many
people as you want to add their photos
to the frame and you never know uh what
fun and embarrassing memories you'll
have to relive right now Aura has a
great deal for Mother's Day listeners
can save the save on the perfect gift by
visiting orframes.com garbage that's
Aura frames.com garbage use code garbage
you get 30 off plus free shipping on
their best selling Carver frame there
you go uh this deal ends on May 14th so
don't wait terms and conditions apply
any vacations growing up you guys go
anywhere you do anything yeah my mom was
big on going to Puerto Rico okay Cuban
yeah okay that's just one for the first
time beautiful a lot of Florida a lot of
Florida Miami and how are you getting
down there you driving down there
Eastern Airlines the wings of man [__]
yeah
Puerto Rico I flew and then my mom put
me on a plane when I was 10 to L.A to go
see my uncle okay so you know when you
attend then like by yourself [__] yeah
my mom didn't have time to dick around
and go to Disneyland the Mets are
playing [__]
[__]
[Applause]
see some [__] Disneyland I don't want
to see no Mickey Mouse let's go to the
mech game let's throw some [__]
chicken wings at Rusty stop and left
field and let's have a good [__] time
my mom wasn't at Disneyland or Sea World
for sure so you'd fly out there your
uncle pick you up at the airport that's
old school [__] they don't do that 10
years old don't do that now get arrested
they do it now you got to pay 18 000.
sure you gotta pay a fee and put that
kid In First Class yeah and he gets
treated like [__] they don't give you no
wings they don't give me no he don't get
the land the plane and they you can't
get off the plane till the end uh so
they make you sit there like a bumpy
because I flew with a kid once next to
me that's not ex that's not great I sat
down and there's like a 12 year old girl
as an adult yeah
this is great this had to be about 60
years ago
she sat I I just I'm 12 years old I'm
going to jail so I just looked straight
ahead I didn't do anything and then she
asked me she goes I have a lot of
anxiety you ever adequate loot okay no I
was she's [__] 12. they'll put me
under the goddamn jail could you imagine
that like if somebody says like Joey
Diaz asked my daughter if she had a
quaalude they'll throw you under the
jail okay you got any lemons on you yeah
or the Aurora 714 Express
you know you've lived a a peppered life
when you can quote out the pill numbers
yeah that's my favorite but you I
figured you would be good guidance for
young kids getting you what you went
through it when it was when it was much
rougher yes you know but she came to me
and she goes I have anxiety I don't know
she goes can you keep your eye on me and
I was like then I spoke to her a little
bit about anxiety I have anxiety and
then she was great and then we landed
and I get off the plane and there's a
[__] dude who's not happy I could
tell he's powerful
I didn't know you know he was with his
wife and they're like why can't I see my
daughter [__] why can't I finally walk
10 steps and I go let me go back and I
went back and like hey man excuse me you
don't know me
your door is fine I sat next door in
first class she's fine she had a little
bit of anxiety but that was it we spoke
about it and he goes thank you very much
yeah you're the kind of guy I want to be
sitting next to him
I didn't find out the next day till they
sent me a message it was Eminem's
manager
and then he sent me anything you need to
reach out to me my daughter said you
were a gentleman look at that Uncle Joe
you want to play he put him under his
wing oh yeah yeah but in today's world
you don't want to talk to little 12 year
olds of course I remember when my
daughter was first born I went to a
five-year-old girl's house we were all
there all the parents and I'm sitting
there with my daughter and the little
girls little girl turned around came up
to me and thank God in front of my wife
and her mother she goes Uncle Joey my
squeegee hurts and I'm like
why are you telling me this
like that's [__] uncomfortable sure
I'm gonna go get a hamburger yeah
my squeegee hurts well why would it hurt
what are you telling me this for
my wife was like what I don't know
if I was a scared little kid and I got
on a plane and I saw you there I would I
would be wrong yeah yeah no because I I
feel comfortable sitting next to him
yeah I was a scared little kid me too
I'm a scared little man yeah so I just
turned the voice down a little bit and
just told them that I had it too and I
just talked to a spoke to her about
breathe you know ask yourself why you
have this fear stop keep breathing and
ask yourself
she was like it's working thank you
man [__] stand-up guy [__] love it
all right so Florida do you ever do
Jersey Shore or anything like that oh
yeah yeah where'd you go uh all of them
because you graduate yeah you're 13 you
go to Kingsburg first and then people
like why you went to Kingsburg that's a
dump okay then they'd take you to like
Seaside then Seaside Park then when you
get into Gorilla Biscuits that's when
you go to Manasquan but The Ultimate Bar
was Belmont Montego Bay yeah and it was
before 12 you could all right so it
opened at 12 and then a little peep went
on the beach
and it was they had a special on Red
Devils it's an Alabama Slammer and a
[__] New York Long Island iced tea
put together mixed that with a quaalude
forget about it I'll never forget going
in there one night wake up but he was so
[__] up on the Quaalude yeah wake up
on Labor Day he was just dancing with
one shoe one
you're missing your shoe he's like what
and if you went in there before six with
your bathing suit you could stay with
your bathing suit on so you could rub up
against the girls
then I left in 84. okay so I didn't
really know what was going on after that
that's good what was Christmas like as a
kid would you guys do uh would you do a
tree
yeah I remember Christmas early on but
the most memorable Christmas I had was I
still lived on 88th Street
and I was with them all night at the bar
now I didn't tell them I didn't believe
him you know when you go up to 148th
Street the kids straighten you right the
[__] out about life they don't give a
[__] about you a 12 year old up there is
42. yeah a 12 year old is 30. yeah
there's no [__] around the first time
you're like hi I can't wait to see Santa
like they know Santa the Dominican
straightened yeah in my house he's
Hector okay there's no [__] Santa
there's no [__] sound
one of the things in the book that
first time I went to 148th Street my
Godmother's like you got to go outside
and play with the kids all right I
started playing you know it was some
[__] Irish dirty kids [__] Puerto
Rican kids and some white kids German
whatever the [__] they were a couple
Jewish kids
I wasn't there an hour and they're like
hey you want to come play and I'm like
yeah we played like stickball or
whatever and then they're like let's go
down to West Side Highway because we
were right there we were uh 148th and
Broadway so all you got to do is walk
down the hill right there and you're
right there and I remember like they're
like we walked in you want to see a dead
body and I remember the dude Jesus was
already like bloated and he had like a
tube like a four by eight piece of
plywood on them this is before New York
City is when you sat there until you sat
there yeah unless you want to unless
you're bothering somebody on Broadway or
in front of the [__] Lincoln Center
they're not coming for you when they
[__] shot you back I don't know if he
was shot I remember we walked and I till
this day I remember the the smell smell
the smell [__] thick it wasn't asthma
that killed him no no it wasn't natural
causes I don't think I hit in the head
with a rock I don't know what happened
to it he was just laying there with
shorts on and a [__] piece of plywood
on them okay all right I'm good that's
good but that was that was a kid's world
yeah that was a New York I mean that was
a kids it was a different New York bag I
mean I didn't know it but different way
different than now huh okay any pets
growing up
yeah I had my mother was a German
Shepherd [__] okay she would donate
money to the asps the cops or something
that was our first dog German Shepherd
and they would give her like the old dog
oh no [__] the ones that couldn't sniff
drugs
when they got too much asthma sleep
apnea whatever so we had a couple German
Shepherds Champion okay and there was
another one I forget
and then I got a dog
about maybe six months before my mother
died and then when my mother died the
Italian house I went to they didn't like
dogs they already had a dog so I had to
give the dog away and I still remember
nights being [__] up and walking home
and going I gotta go see that dog and I
would jump to people's fence and just go
into the doghouse with the dog and just
cry oh [__] just missing my mother in
this [__] dog damn I was doing THC
Crystal back then
which is called which is so there might
not have been a dog no no it was a dog
which was which was AKA Angel Dustin
sure sure AKA so we like doing this [__]
every Sunday we would do a ten dollar
bag from the city of angel dust so when
I got the dog I ended up calling Crystal
he was he was white with a couple like
little black marks he looks like
crystals so I called the Crystal and
after that then I got dogs later on okay
no snakes anything like that lizards
Birds nothing turtles
that okay huh when you were in school
would you bring a lunch or would you
would your mom pack you one what would
you do
early on uh you know what I got here
from Cuba I wanted to be an American
okay and my life was Dick Van Dyke okay
and [__] Dick Van Dyke Show with Mary
Tyler Moore yeah that's right hot dog
okay and in my mind I believe that the
more hot dogs I ate the more American I
would get in a rush it was like a speed
to be able to hit a number and you got
your green card or whatever yeah Green
Card at 250 you get your green card big
fan of the sabrettes big fat the best
big fan big fans they don't even have in
the city really anymore it's just the
umbrellas it's [__] oh really yeah
they don't use
umbrellas you can get them out at the at
the factory out in Jersey I got them at
the house I'm coming over with the
onions do you get the onions I love
their chili sauce oh I love the chili so
good the red onions and you get the
chili sauce and cut little jalapenos and
dope it up even more oh Lordy
you don't know what's [__] up that
[__] if it's the hot dogs or the
[__] Hollies
[Music]
what would you say would be the best way
to cook a hot dog
how do you do them at the house at the
house if I tell you you'll be mad at me
no no fry those [__] with raw
onions in them on a pan on a pan okay I
like fried rice I like my hot dogs all
types let's interject real quick please
and this is how much I like hot dog
okay if there's anybody ever built for
the show it's Joey I have to I have to
resist yeah we might be related I'm
telling you right now I have to resist
getting a hot dog oh damn like let's be
honest there's a place in Seaside Park
but I want walked into one day and they
had a special 10 hot dogs for 20 bucks
so I'm out 60 bucks
I went for the 10 first
and that's scary that you could eat 10
[__] hot dogs
these guys make fun of me all the time
when I was a kid I was born in upstate
Pennsylvania we had this place called
Abe's hot dogs and we'd always get them
and we'd get them by the Dozen and we
would if we would eat like three four
hot dogs yeah just the best
yours were chili dogs and you ate you
said they only sold them by the Dozen
and we found out you can buy one chili
dog if you're new or just a year well
you were just eating 12 chili dogs when
we were in a weight loss challenge so
that's why we were a little upset we
gotta go for hot dogs once yeah there's
a place in Newark yeah there's a place
in Clifton maybe it's called Hank
Springs okay hot dogs you get one free
and they you get potatoes on your hot
dogs and onions and [__] come on now you
[__] blood for a month but it's [__]
worth it it's better to eat that [__]
hummus okay
I'd rather eat 20 hot dogs and a [__]
piece of hummus and support buck and
Isis and God knows what else
all right that's why you haven't seen
Isis they've been laying low yeah
pumping it pumping it [__]
I'm a hummus man I like a little hummus
I do but I mean
you're from Philly come on your parents
know about this yeah yeah yeah you're
from Philly there's a certain [__]
respect I have always had the
Philadelphia it's a Philly New York in
Boston no no no I love Boston I love New
York City and what it stands for when
New York City [__]
sneezes every other [__] catches
a cold and you better [__] remember
that now [__] don't get too well
it's happening in Sacramento listen New
York City is the way to [__] go okay
still always will be will be Philly
Philly
we were talking about hot dogs
I got back I got back here three years
ago and I was a little [__] up for a
year I did the knee surgery I was having
some problems
and Jimmy Florentine goes I got sick
tickets for the Philly game against uh
the Giants do you want to go and I'm
like absolutely
I pulled my daughter aside what the time
was nine I go listen doll I love you to
death but where we're going
you're going to hear things yeah sure
you've never heard before okay and
forgive they're cool people that
Dynamite people trust me I'm telling you
this just we get there we're not even in
the stadium my daughter hits me she goes
look dad there was already a dick on the
wall with a ball right when you walked
in for some people they go oh my God for
me I'm like I'm home it feels good I'm
[__] home start tearing up I walked
down I had we had great tickets Jimmy
and I ain't [__] people yelling shut
the [__] up the coach from San Francisco
wouldn't come out because I guess he
coached Philadelphia yeah yeah he
coached every time that guy walked out
the things yeah you heard yeah again I
love Philadelphia sometimes it's
Overkill short in my world where I came
from I like it because yeah Philadelphia
don't like the same [__] I don't [__]
all this [__] it's very tame
now back when we were kids
oh
remember I went to Glassboro okay before
it became Rowan [__] okay that's
how old The Relic papa is yeah so I
still remember the six of games when
they would give you a free hamburger if
they scored over 125 points and if you
shout out to the Spectrum if you had
balls go cop that burger yeah because
you got the free ticket and you got to
walk in there walking out with that
burger
uh
I went to see the stones with Florida
and veterans in 1978. Jesus I was there
when Julius cupped the ball against the
Lakers getting one get the [__] out of
here really didn't one I saw the Daily
News I was I was working for a boogie on
118th Street I took the thought there
was no ferry that I had to take the bus
up [__] Boulevard East and I you know
you had the Daily News that's what when
you get into the city you buy daily
daily news in the [__] sad breath
that's what you're doing wherever you
got to go you read The Daily News and
I'll never forget that scene Philly was
getting the point at home
hello
[__] forget about a year
earlier hitting Dallas going to San
Francisco and try to give my man snowy
Joey a point and what did that
[__] do he threw He Turned the
Lights Off with Clark that was my
functioning who the [__] are you to come
into Philly [__] Kareem [__] magic
that's when we have Moses [__] we had
World be free we had a [__] stack
team called will Jones bar or whatever
Doctor Jones Julia serving it was a
different [__] world man okay let's
talk about rocking Money Baby rocket
money let's talk about rocket money
saving you money because we're all
signed up to all these subscriptions
that we thought we canceled that we
don't know about meanwhile it's coming
out of your checking account and then
something hits and then you're overdrawn
now you're jammed up most people think
that they drop about 80 bucks a month on
subscriptions it's actually about 200
with rocket money they go through it
tell you exactly what you got subscribed
up to they can cancel it for you right
then and there boom I know I signed up
they were good enough they gave us a
nice little promo code to sign up check
it out you know I mean I didn't realize
I was signed up for dildo of the month
club hey we're taking 14 a month out of
my goddamn pie I'm not making with the
dildo I know if you're sending the
equipment all right yeah uh quickly and
easily view all your subscription and
cancel any time anyone you don't want
with just touch of a button they take
care of the rest for you rocket money
even puts uh your expenses into
categories and alert you if anything
looks off and budgeting is uh is in Easy
Mode baby
um those five dollar charges you think
are this that that adds up after a while
Jamie up keep it in your pocket don't
even let them get their greedy little
hands on it stop throwing away stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
garbage that's rocketmoney.com garbage
rocketmoney.com garbage do it
being a little Suburban kid and going
down to the vet for the first time in
the 80s that was a [__] eye opener oh
yeah it was an eye eye opener you held
your dad's hand real fast
you saw a fist fight or something like
that closer to me yeah yeah this ain't
working out petrified it was it was a
different yeah that veteran Stadium even
I mean I would go in the 90s it was
[__] weight you know it was a
[__] they had a jail cell and a judge in
there it's a processor that's [__]
crazy yeah that's nuts people don't
believe that yeah like people outside
you know California people don't believe
that no but like I also view people
every time everywhere you go they're
like all Philly fans Phillies and I'm
just used to it so I'm like I don't know
but then as I've been removed I've been
up here for 10 years I go back I'm like
oh yeah no it is fun yeah but let me ask
you a question I love it I would rather
go see a game in Philly oh yeah than
anywhere else anymore we were at the
World Series game three first game back
in Philly when Harper when they were
just crushing crushing they were laying
it right in our phone right behind
Castellanos Harper hit that first bomb
let me tell you it was like Moneyball
it was not magic everybody's got
everybody in a headlock beer it's fine
the next night they live for that [__]
Yeah
man they live for that that's a
beautiful thing to see and bro I grew up
at the Garden seen Bernard King sure you
know I went to see the guard to see [__]
and
it was [__] you know a couple weeks
ago there was a game from the garden I
was watching I'm like [__] will
never know what that's like a Tuesday
night in New York City [__] yeah the
mixer at home and remember now it's 400
a ticket but when I was crazy we'd just
be hanging out what are you guys doing
tonight let's go to [__] Nick
I steak and we'll shoot up and get the
nickname we'll smoke a joint on the way
get a six-pack whatever that's how it
works joint six pack in a bowl that's
how you walk you got off the port
authority and you walked to the Garden
smoking and people look at you with a
[__] ghetto blaster AC DC Highway to
Hell you know people like these [__]
kids these kids came to play they were
on their own planet
oh man all right so we talked about hot
dog how do you get your steak cooked Joe
how do you like your steak medium well
medium well medium well really yikes a
little pink but I I can't have all that
[__] pink yeah really I like roast
beef but like when they give you too
much pink it just drives me crazy no
kidding hey yeah so you want to you
won't do like tartar or anything like
that will you like steak tartar try it
what about oysters will you have raw
oysters yeah oysters clams oysters
really okay lamb is on a half shell like
a [__]
[Laughter]
Uncle Joey how do you feel about Hibachi
restaurants tremendous I got a great one
in my neighborhood really yeah and they
doubled listen I don't like going to
restaurants when they have two flags you
gotta pick a flag with maybe you're
Chinese oh so you'll okay so if they
have an American flag and a Chinese if
you try me I don't want to see sushi in
your restaurant don't embarrass me okay
let's work on the lobster Cantonese okay
but if you're gonna make sushi too it's
the law of diminishing returns you're
gonna hear it somewhere yeah so I always
I'm a full Japanese you want Japanese if
you go Chinese you want Chinese we do
Korean barbecue yeah not bad but by my
house they have a Japanese place and
they do Pad Thai shrimp okay
yeah perfect perfect
I used to go to toy in L.A that was
right down the corner from me the only
thing I didn't like was they have
coconut milk and people will Barefoot
those granola [__] in L.A their
feet smell like that you know all that
yoga and all that rotten ass and all
that turmeric and [__] they're in there
real deodorant yeah like you're [__]
eating Pad Thai shrimp you think you're
under the [__] Hudson yeah oh yeah
those [__] filthy Gentiles no no
[__] you know you know Los Angeles
must have been a war every single day of
your life
we're going to battle you know it's so
weird
it's so weird I just could not
I cannot believe I lasted 23 years
and then at some point I would just shut
people up like I don't want to hear this
[__] yeah too much talking too Mama shut
the [__] up if you're gonna get on stage
oh you're not uh that's it right or
wrong what's the question well I thought
that I would write this material and
then live through it shut the [__] up
just get up and be funny all this [__]
for nothing just get up there yeah the
[__] is all this [__]
Jesus now you said you said you're not
you're not that big of a fan of flying
but when you do fly you up front
fly up front
I'll fly wherever they put me you know
but yeah you're trying to fly up you
know you sat in the back you've done it
all yeah sure yeah yeah so Club listen
the club gives you like
600 for a plane ticket okay can I go
online the plane tickets 800 for an
extra 150 I get to live like a doctor
sure I get to scratch my balls in first
class but the only first class I was
really really in love with the best I
think is JetBlue okay oh the what is it
the mint or whatever yeah oh by yourself
your pot you're in a pot you're in the
pot Yeah by your little office will you
take your shoes off on a plane
I love people so no okay I don't want
them smelling My Fun Life Will You
Dropped a seat back
yeah yeah okay UTSA pre-check no I'm I
got felonies I'm uh I'm clear
but every once in a while they [__] up
and they give me pre-checking them later
yeah okay
uh you brush your teeth in the shower
yes and no I have like two places like
in the shower and then I have the
thankful anything you gotta go in there
three times a day so you can't keep
going back in the shop
toothbrush in my shower in my bathroom
one downstairs in the basement you leave
it in the shower one in the shower will
you pee in the shower I used to I used
to [__] in the shower too for a while
a nice little dump in there you pick it
up with your hand and just flip it in
the toilet in the morning show two birds
with one stone
but that was a long time ago that was
when I was still an animal no that's a
first yeah here on the program ladies
and gentlemen
you want the truth I got to give it to
you of course and we appreciate that Joe
make me come over a ferry to come here
and blow lies
I got on that Ferry I'm gonna make it
worth a while
dinner with a couple of friends and at
someone's birthday will you tell the
waiter at someone's birthday so you get
the free cake no no never I don't want
that [__] coming to my table
okay with that firecracker they're
singing he's the job to get the [__] out
of it yeah get the [__] out of here I
just had a 60th birthday and my friends
were Furious like you gotta have
something
oh my gosh I'm not doing that [__] so
what I did was I got all my neighbors to
bring their kids over and we [__]
made pizzas there you go and the kids
had a great time we listened to music
the parents got hammered and I had the
energy of the kids there we got I got
too many kids in my neighborhood for me
to tell you I'm coming home without the
kids I can't do that sure yeah you know
somebody sent me an invite for dinner
last week oh yeah no kids like I got two
I'm too invested sure and my daughter
would just stay I don't really have a
babysitter all the time
so no nah I like kids okay what about
how do you feel about splitting the
check when you go out to eating I'd
rather pay it just so I don't have to
[__] see calculated [__] come out in
percentages of who drank the wine oh you
didn't drink listen just give me the
[__] check cause you're embarrassing
I know it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing it's okay and if I don't
have it just to get the conversation
over the best is in L.A when they invite
you when they go hey this is It's
Chuck's Birthday Tuesday you wanna wait
till you go to his 18 [__] at
the table too much for me because they
just want to talk to you on you there's
18 [__] interjecting in our
stories and then wait for the check to
come then nobody knows nothing
you know everybody saw him what happened
I think you know because all they're
talking about is I can't wait to travel
to India you know you're not going
anywhere anywhere yeah check comes mom's
the check comes mom you know everybody's
looking the other way yeah all I got is
rupees yeah
what do you like to lay down on a tip
you're a good temper yes good temper
okay listen man we're entertainers yeah
yeah better yeah yeah
we're in the art business better yet
we're really in the karma business I
love that that's pretty good yeah that
just hit me we're pretty much gonna call
my business
so look at the book look what it says on
the bottom of that book it says Joey
Coco Diaz and underneath
Erica Florence Erica florentine's
Jimmy's niece okay
she can't figure out like why'd you put
me on the book why'd you do this and I
go when you're a real artist you look
for people to strive yeah of course
I'ma tell you why I learned this lesson
from guys it's got 200 million dollars
I just got 200 million dollars because
he never felt short on us at any of his
friends you know he was always there for
us he was making money since day one so
don't think of 200 200 million dollars
ever changed that she was making money
but the support that you get from Big
Time names and you see that and when you
first get into the business you're like
oh I don't like this guy or [__] him
he's moving faster than me that's gonna
stunt your growth does the more you
cheer for these two [__] the
bigger you'll be because you're cheering
you want the best of everybody around
you and it comes down to tipping it
comes down to kids yeah you know tipping
that's listen I'm gonna sit here with
you and tell you about bad as far as I'm
concerned it's all bad service you know
why because they're not licking my ball
flag okay I'm saying like let's be
honest what's good service they lick my
ball sack after I had the flan and a
double espresso okay that's not gonna
happen but you know what's a great
dessert by the way you're making this
hahaha
you're you're making that person's day I
always say that all I got to do is one
thing every day just make somebody's day
does that mean you have to give them 10
million dollars no that means bro I like
that shirt really I like you Joey my
wife hates it [__] your [__] wife you
know what I'm saying that's two nice
things you make somebody's death of
course guys if it's buying them a sad
Red Dog what they cost you three dollars
yeah what's it cost you to take a guy on
the road that
you know he's you know when a comic's
down sure I don't have to tell you that
you have two good weeks and then you
have three bad weeks this guy don't want
to use you Netflix don't want to shoot
me [__] all that let's go to [__]
Boston let's go do it again dope let's
go let's see what the [__] going on
here and people never understood that
everybody's done challenging everybody
that's not the way you're going to grow
you're going to grow by clapping for
that [__] completely you know
there's a thousand Comics I don't like
personally but God damn it are they
[__] funny do you follow me yeah I'm
still gonna support him maybe I don't
like what they do and guess what maybe
they don't like what I do but they got
to go that [__] to tell a good
story and that's what this is basically
about we're in the karma business gosh
damn it's all right [__] changing
lives out of here oh Joey win the karma
business [__] I I I I become a
better Tipper I didn't have money for so
long and now I got cash I'll go oh I'm
I'm making up so like the guys that are
getting it now are getting it for the
for the 10 guys
there was a time even if I didn't have
money I wouldn't go in that restaurant
sure oh yeah if I couldn't give him
three dollars you know what don't go in
there yeah you can't stiff a guy you're
not gonna stiff a [__] guy never
hmm damn using any cologne you wear
cologne [__] no no Irish Spring [__]
yeah shout out to the Irish Irish
Springs a bar of soap [__] yeah are you
bar on skin uh I used to be more like
now she my wife buys like the loofah I
like the loofah I cut a little loofah
for your [__] because you're around
the sides you get that little Barnacles
and [__] to stay on there so you look
for that little Muffler you're making my
own muscle that's why I keep the [__]
toothbrush in it's on the other side of
the toothbrush
Irish Spring and the stickiest yeah oh I
love that [__] I love Irish Spring I'm
white trash Guys you 've had I'm Cuban
but I'm white trash I tell my wife all
the time I don't feel bad I'm white
trash too you're making Cuban sandwiches
and Wonder Bread oh no not that one
trash but I have my I love all the shits
over it hit you yeah I love all that I
apologize zombie hey I apologize I
didn't know he was gonna say that none
I am white trash brother uh have you
ever skied in jeans yes okay
Jersey what are you gonna do it's true
you have any bumper stickers on the car
now no okay how do you feel about the
rotisserie chicken
it's kind of boring though okay it used
to be better than everybody you know
Boston Market did it they had a good
[__] day
threw down they threw down then ShopRite
got into it everybody got into it and
now you're getting these third world
[__] chickens that taste like [__]
ass okay you know it's like the sandwich
Mr manicani made you a sandwich to
Philadelphia and it was a great [__]
sandwich for three dollars but that no
then there's got to be Subway it's
you're not gonna go into the subway but
they [__] it up for everybody else they
do the products so Mr manicotti now you
know now you got people going into hi
Miss America got a turkey on white come
here for a second well I look like I
make turkey on white get the [__] out of
here
where are you shopping now over in
Jersey what's your grocery store over
there
I got three different ones okay
okay where are you getting your lunch
meat from yeah
it's an Italian Italian Market you go
there for the specialty items yeah and
then get a little [__] mortadell with
a little [__] wet much okay a little
piece of bread they got uh Gino's
Italian ice and that [__] shout
out to Gino's they also got I I can't
support them because they don't support
cops Ben and Jerry's New York super
fudge chunk I love that [__]
that's a that's a game changer if you
want diabetes there you go Ben and
Jerry's I'll do it I'm a Chubby Hubby
man I know what you're talking about
yeah yeah all right
um and what cold country what what
regular cold cuts are you doing you do
turkey you do ham I'm a deluxe Boar's
Head Deluxe ham gentlemen slices
thin will you take the slice off the guy
when he slices it bet like a
[__] you bet I'm a Costco
groupie [__] I love that [__] I know it
is to be poor on a Saturday and go to
Costco and mingle
I'm going to Costco to mingle you're
treating like it's a wine taste yeah I
don't have no money to buy anything
do you want a piece of Alabama
um I shouldn't I shouldn't
he got 40 toothpicks in your pocket yeah
who's cutting the hair these days where
you get the haircut
well I'm 60. my hair cuts itself at this
point I'm just losing it back today
it cuts this up and I have a girl that
I've been using in Jersey great lady I
know her family okay my father is the
gym I go to okay you go to her she come
to you I go to her you go to the house
or she got a spot no she got a shop
great shop I love the girls what's she
getting you for a cut over there how
much the cut costs again I don't even
know she just gives me a number and I
give birth yeah I know she takes care of
me on it I go in there for the dye the
cut gotcha fill it all up you get the
whole thing the [__] nose is sure
clean you up real nice yeah I just
started getting the nose hair into your
hair done when I go in yeah
get to that age it just blows out you
um let's say you're going to a wedding
uh family friend their kid
um what are we talking about in the
envelope
what are we looking at I assume you're a
cash gift guy you're not getting some of
the registry no I'm not giving them a
[__] blender like a Momo well let's
get something straight
I give everybody from three to the
nickel but I can't go to the wedding
that is the most [__] I've ever
heard I will pay you 500 not to go to
your way
I'm like Brad Pitt Moneyball when he's
talking to that dude yeah and he goes
the Yankees are paying you not to play
yeah you know I'm David Jefferson you go
to so many weddings and they're a whole
[__] day
three to a nickel I just don't have it
you know and then all of a sudden 15
years ago something started in this
country where it really turned me off
and it's the people who think again it's
a special day for you and I'm there with
you but what makes you think I gotta fly
to Texas to celebrate your birthday or
to Mexico and I got one invite let me
tell you what this invite was about and
I'll tell you the background I know we
want a shortage I knew the girl she was
a sweet girl we lived in the building
but what pissed me off was she got a
pair of fake tits that look fantastic I
never saw him but she was a skinny girl
and the tits looked great and she got
engaged two months after she got the
tits she didn't even [__] wait to see
where her investment was going to take
her nobody ever came on a pitch nobody
[__] jizz nobody did anything so for
you to get married okay when I got the
invite but
this young lady decided to get married
January 1st oh and she wanted you there
December 26th for the festivities let me
tell you crazy get out of here [__] you
who the [__] are you to get married in
Mexico first of all I knew you when you
were sucking dick behind White Castle
okay I knew all those broads when they
were giving handjobs buying White Castle
a Burger King or McDonald's now I gotta
fly to Mexico no that's never gonna I
will never contribute to that address I
will never contribute to that okay
because I don't want people to keep
thinking they can get away with that get
married at the VFW like every other
dirty [__] [__] does okay
I knew you when you were blown dudes and
now all of a sudden you want to get
married because your husband bought you
a Range Rover it's like the other day
somebody tried to cut me off with a
Mercedes Benz she didn't know what she
was doing
she didn't no she didn't really know
what she was doing she tried to I was
already in place and she's trying to
muscle in on me and I opened the car and
I told her something that's as simple as
can be okay
sucking dick and driving are two
different skills
just cause your husband bought you a
hundred thousand dollar car because you
suck a good dick you can't drive and
that's not on me so before you buy your
wife a hundred thousand dollar car I'm
I'm sure she could suck dick but let's
take it for a driver's day let's make
sure she's not gonna aggravate people
but on the other hand the reason why you
bought that because you're [__] your
receptionist so you're never gonna take
the ride with her anyway so why you know
yeah I'm sorry
this is what we want I guess don't cut
Joey Diaz I get him more she didn't want
me to your wedding she didn't cut me off
she beeped at me and tried to like yeah
[__] her move back no you didn't cut in
yeah you would [__] busy looking
around
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so 302 a nickel is what yeah but I'm not
going to your [__] wedding
and I'm listening my daughter already
talked to me about a 16 year old
quinceanera or whatever the 16th Street
sure I told you see the sweet 16 of
college there's no sweepstakes in there
in my [__] house okay well I'm a
Cuban kid I had to go to a sweet 16. I
went to one of them uh-huh [__] you [__]
your grandmother being there holding my
hand yeah I'm Spanish when I was a kid I
used to have to take the girl and her
grandmother to [__] the movies if I
had that option today if a woman comes
up to me you could take me to the movies
my grandmother [__] you and [__] your
[__] dirty [__] grandmother I'm not
going to movies with none of you unless
she's looking one ball and you're
licking the other I'm not going to
movies with you [__] lynches but when
you're a kid you agree that God yeah
sure trying to get your dick wet yeah
why is Grandma here busting my body up
and [__]
uh what was the last time you were at an
Applebee's TGI Fridays or Olive Garden
here really okay respectable you still
doing any fast food at all will you have
fast food No don't touch it back when
you were doing it what was your what was
your go-to you can't say in and out
because I know that's Superior no uh
when I lived on 88th Street I was not
allowed as a child to eat fast food okay
so the only time I could eat fast food
when I went to visit my cousins in Miami
and we would get McDonald's or KFC which
okay you know the 70s and 80s sure
that's when KFC had real chicken that
was unbelievable McDonald Big Macs were
[__] King yeah they were awesome and
then over the years you hear all this
[__] and you know yeah
I can't lie to you I had a quarter
pounder about three weeks ago at night I
was stoned there was nothing to eat at
the house this is a 24-hour one by my
house and I gotta tell you something it
was [__] amazing yeah yeah it tasted
that [__] good as you're eating it
you're like I know that my intestines
are gonna be bleeding and [__] blood for
a month and whatever but it doesn't
matter on that particular night that
[__] quarter pounder with cheese was
delicious yeah I won't go back now for
six months yeah yeah yeah I'll go on
every six months it ain't bad but I tell
you what else I like that egg McMuffin
apple pie
dude [__] no McDonald's McDonald's
not even [__] they're getting they're
getting the uncut pure not stepped on
[__] yeah everybody else is getting
stepped on [__] McDonald's comes correct
will you dip your fries in mayo if you
have french fries no
uh what kind of air freshener you got in
a car right now rifa
[Laughter]
called Weed [__]
shut up you get the car wash on the
regular
keep the car clean yes and no and what
are you whipping around then if you
don't mind us asking what are you Subaru
Subaru alive okay okay lived in Colorado
for 12. sure yeah you know last week it
was raining in Jersey I could see these
jerk loss doing 30. I'm doing 90 where's
you buy them beep beep vote for me
[__]
enjoy your [__] Prius oh we got
electrocuted [__]
wait to get electrocuted you and Tesla
all he is Joey zipping around in the
Subaru I [__] love it that's all
right it makes so much sense yeah uh you
take the shoes off in the house or you
leave the shoes on
my wife don't want me to take my shoes
off the stink is unreal really nah she
doesn't care I take the shoes off take
them off say you go over someone's house
for dinner or something or whatever I
don't take them off and they say take
them off [__] you
I lost my father
foreign
I assume we got a king-sized bed at the
house yes okay uh how many pillows you
sleep with
there's nine on the bed there's nine on
the bed three holy my thing and then
she's got something in the middle okay
you know my wife is from Tennessee she's
always got an acre pain gotcha how many
so you have two underneath your head or
three underneath your head two or three
two or three do you hold one you put one
between the legs no I'm too busy holding
the cat okay you snuggle with the kitty
the cat comes up right now yeah all
right
ceiling fan ceiling fan fan on when you
sleep fan
ceiling fan standing fan air conditioner
and a little fan that blows this way I
put the sleep apnea mask on I throw some
nights I sleep with a hooded sweatshirt
on just on principal because I don't I'd
rather freeze than be hot Gotcha Man
three fans going you got a TV in the
room yes you leave the TV on when you
sleep turn it off yeah okay that's all
right I have sleep apnea so I had to
program myself that when I hit the bed
I'm going to sleep gotcha shutting it
down yeah I'm not going to watch TV I
watch TV downstairs I got it too do you
like to see Pat machine yes yeah it's my
favorite my favorite it red sues me it
puts me to sleep people I don't like it
I like the way it feels I [__] love
what are your [__] options yeah I
love it what are the options to die in
time I love it
it's funny if I fall asleep now would it
only for some reason and I don't nap
during the day anymore because I use it
but if for some reason I fall asleep on
a couch or at it man I wake up like I'm
like I'm coming out of Vietnam people
have no idea how bad it is and how bad
it gets it elevates quickly yeah I
thought I had heart I thought I had
heart problems for a long time because I
went to the I went to the
um the cardiologist before I ended up
going to the pulmonologist when I got
insurance a couple years ago and I was
like dude I'm waking up in the middle of
the night and I think I'm having a heart
attack turns out that was just my body
shocking me with adrenaline because of
my sleep apnea it's crazy man not no
more I'm out night I was number one
growing disease in men sleep apnea and
it wasn't until our boy in Philly died
that it woke it all up was it Philly
who's that are we talking about defense
event
uh talking about Reggie White Reggie
White yeah
up to the up to the up to Reggie White's
death that website was getting 25
000 hits a year maybe huh on the day of
his death two days after his death his
website got a million downloads people
on the app people didn't know they had
it I didn't know guys I didn't know I
had it yeah I was falling asleep with a
cigarette in my hand like a [__]
heroin junkie and I was in uh Little
Rock Arkansas I was having a lot of
problems I didn't know I was putting on
excessive weight quickly I was putting
on weight on 40 pound chunks damn I
bought three suits at Hollywood Suit
Outlet one time in like a martian three
suits like a Puerto Rican three suits
three shirts three pairs of socks and
shoes yeah quinceanera shoes [__] and
guys I have no reason to lie I bought
them like early March for a commercial
and I think mid-april I went to put them
on like you know sometimes you put pants
on you're like oh man I gained the pound
and you squeeze into the guys I was
three inches apart like it was really
hard to get there like who does that who
could [__] gain three inches and that
went up all the way up to 418 pounds I
know a guy
a guy too
I also met a gentleman
gentleman so I'll take them off your
hands I told you [__] tons of [__]
what's the Wardrobe like you got Suits
now how many suits you got now do you
think do you wear or I got about eight
suits eight suits I think that's a
record yeah but
I stole roller skates when I did movies
and [__] like that but I just bought
suits over the years I like suit I like
dressing up yeah but it's like I was
telling somebody I bought a nice jacket
for The Grudge Match for me okay how
many times I've won it for The Grudge
Match yeah yeah yeah yeah I do the same
[__] that's it you know I want to feel
nice you want to look good and you know
I've gone there a guy that wears a suit
you know what I mean I'm not that I'm
not that suits are bad luck weddings
court and funerals yeah that's it
they're the only time I wear them you
got a [__] suits are bad a lot yeah
holy [__] think about it that's a
[__] Revelation all you wear suit for
is for [__] bad things Court weddings
yeah [__] church people dying you
never wore yeah you never wore you know
good luck yeah they're like hey I want a
million bucks get the suit off yeah yeah
[__] oh you know how to tie a tie no who
ties it for you my wife okay ever been
bitten by a dog a couple times
but not as a burglar but because that's
where his head went but because but
because of fear when I was a kid I was
scared of dogs I kept getting bit bit
bit bit I got bit in the face in the
Bronx when I was like four my mom had a
dry cleaner up there it was a boogie
operation and we had a German Shepherd
to protect the place his name was killer
and here I am [__] with him with him by
taking his ham and throwing it out of
the [__] just reached up
oh man all right where are you going on
vacation now you like to you like to get
away you go down anywhere according out
of banks you go to the Outer Banks nice
okay this this will be our second year
okay myself five other families all
their kids nice [__] great house are
these old big houses they got big houses
down there yeah are these all the
network that you've built out in Jersey
for moving out here yes my wife real
kids and other parents no actual family
members like her family it's just all
Community yeah her family's in Tennessee
no [__] my family's in Cuba are dead I
got an uncle he's 85 he's still in L.A
no kidding and you really built it out
here that's [__] awesome now the
Outer Banks for a little while yeah I
like the Outer Banks this year we're
going to Tennessee to visit our family
okay nice go to Nashville for a week
there you go [__] chicken sure yeah
yeah you ever go to [__] Tennessee go
to a place called Lee's Fried Chicken
these Fried Chicken oh cheese fries deep
deep
deep in the valley like two hours from
Nashville how does it stack up to Hattie
B's down there Hattie B's is phenomenal
yeah spicy yeah leaves is that old
brother flavor okay yeah they don't wear
a hand that's yeah yeah whatever happens
happens
I think I get when you're laying down
yeah
it's old school
authentic I'm with you I love it
that's all right ah I only got a couple
more here yeah uh have you ever asked
for a receipt at a toll booth no okay
do you take the customer receipt with
you if you use the card that's like
you're checking out at the restaurant
yeah sometimes take it with my wife
because she's the accountant what about
if you uh if you go into like a 7-Eleven
or a store and you pay with the credit
card you ever get cash back if you pay
with your debit card you ever say give
me a 20 or whatever sometimes no it's
been years okay respectable all right uh
have you ever called and requested a
song on the radio
oh
he's gonna hit me for a second
the own binoculars
no
do you own an air fryer yeah my wife
just got one yeah
I have just jerseys Jersey New York
stuff what's your go-to pizza place now
I'm in Jersey and I have I'm surrounded
by myself there Jay got good food great
food listen I'm surrounded by Staten
Island people and they know how to throw
down all the restaurants in Jersey yeah
are pretty much Staten Island people yes
Staten Island gets money they go to
Jersey they go to Jersey they go to
Brooklyn goes to Staten Islands Staten
Island goes to Jersey I got a nice
restaurant uh Pizza my neighbor deninos
oh sounds good Staten Island company and
then I got another one Carlos from
Staten Island they're phenomenal and
then I have another one night by my Jiu
Jitsu school it's called Uh crispy okay
it seems from like from from when you
know when we grow up we grew up in The
Burbs and you know all the good food was
in was in the city and stuff like that
and we've lived in the city we've lived
in Philly we lived in New York but the
Suburban South Jersey North Jersey area
the Suburban Philly area pizza places
the the food the sandwiches the food out
there has
gotten so much better than in the cities
I feel they're just unbelievable spots
you can't there's no good Sandwich Spot
in the city anymore you got to go to a
bodega and they give you like they throw
two pieces of American cheese at you on
on white toast sucks you know Joe called
me this morning because the UFC's in
time and he sent me a text and he goes I
want to go to this place in Jersey
there's a restaurant 800 feet from my
house nice holy [__] holy [__] good
stuff it's called El Nido it's organic
Italian
so if you want chicken cutlets parmesan
is not that shrimp Palm nah they got no
lasagna they got like blackened squid
yeah with [__] toe crab crab toes
they got everything is organic the
chicken when you look at the chicken
you're like this don't look right here
because you've never seen this yeah
you're used to saying steroided chicken
it's white like that newspaper really
it's so [__] delicious there man so
yeah if he comes down tonight maybe
we'll go over there that's in South
that's in [__] more bro yeah out in
The Burbs I'm telling you yeah they got
good food guys they're not [__]
around down there now you know you do
one Italian Dish what is it escaroleum
Beans really
that's the classiest answer we've ever
caught that just pulled you out of
skiing and jeans god with pancetta
little pieces of jute okay I'll take it
to a place right now if you want to go
right
get the ferry it's three miles from the
ferry it's called Rudy's
they make a [__] escaroleum Bean
thing you're going to when you eat the
escarole you're going to an Italian
trance like
you start hearing Prairie Como Mexican
[__]
cousins and no no no no there's a place
by me Osteria
when you go in there they don't have a
cup of it so you can't order with
anything else it's escarole and beans
and I just got a loaf of bread and
crushed red pepper and cheese parmesan
cheese and you're good to [__] go
that's it huh door baby man
I'm I'm good here I'm [__] solid what
are you thinking Kim I mean I love them
to death the escarole try but I mean
he's trash and I [__] love it baby
you are [__] white trash as you said
white trash he's the only Cuban white
trash guy I know you got red pepper
flakes of class
little ones I'll tell you that ladies
and gentlemen Mr Joey Diaz the book is
tremendous the life of a comedy Savage
you have to check this out it is
unbelievable Joey congratulations thank
you this is guys thank you very much for
having me great we can't thank you I
didn't know if I should contact you guys
I didn't know anything I'm like those
guys are big time no what are you
talking about we've been trying to get
you for two years
osmosis I'm like what the [__] is going
on but guys thank you for having me this
has been a great [__] thing buddy
thank you so much everybody make sure
you listen to Joey's joint as I'm sure
you do
um Kippy what do you got for him we're
all we're all over the road get tickets
live shows are selling out we [__]
love you thank you for the support baby
gang we love you Joey we love you thank
you so much guys awesome thank you gang
we'll see you next week